e la gt ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo tornati
su si opti come sempre sto giocando su
xbox one hicks e sono con pietro
stavolta siamo solo in due però che
video vi piace buona visione
bonjour tu le mamme più anche a te tasha
ecco oggi alla volta dell'oceano
cercheremo un qualcosa in particolare il
cervello di pietro da allora senti
facciamo così ti prometto che se non fai
cagate non ti insulto più per tutti però
il kraken va trovato il kraken per chi
non lo sapesse è un polipo grosso e
molti hanno detto di aver avvistato il
crac greco sono caduto nella quale la
punta della barca è una barca era uno
alla botte un suo amico secondo me la
becchiamo secondo me una nave da singola
non da due ed un rilassante che dovevamo
incredibile guarda se quanto ne quando
vai e fai gli scontri con cui ho
imparato a far percorso le vele non so
se visto e basta che scendi con flash e
risa giocatore attivarsi tutto il rock
in bocca il secondo te 60 sulla scala mi
aggrappo ruolo che i signori amico seo
nell'h e quale sta questa la si è
fermata e al porto e porto al portone
magia ginestra si ricorda incornata in
corner incornata abbiamo avuto una nave
da me ne frega niente incorna abbiamo
abbiamo lavorato dietro vice palla di
suonare per la qualità né preso in pieno
gli ho ripreso in pieno
teorie ripresi quando danno che la
sostanza da taglio fatto un disastro
guardavi che cecchino oggi ma cosa fanno
come hanno fatto gravissimo
ok lucilio ok perfetto li abbiamo
respinti occhio il galeone ancora dietro
con ciò che facciamo li salutiamo la
mano destra
se mi spari sopra vi faccio il danno di
centrarlo pietro c'erano madonna ma poi
f con un genio porca vacca ma dai dritto
ma spara dritto che un unico berne per
vai vai vai avanti in arrivo quasi
record che adesso arrivando sono lì non
so proprio cosa è successo niente
proposto riprendiamo li prendiamo tutta
la vita si no successo
vai vai vai vai a occhio che c'era lei
mamma mia legge
mamma mamma mia rega e ora si store è
diffuso occhio fonti occhi occhi occhio
nei loro armi e workshop
da tempo abbiamo visto mentre si è
schiantato trovato ok cuore è uscito
lucido ma come io la loro io lavorerò
viola loro allora la nostra barca siamo
scambiati baci scambiati barca torna
sulla nostra e non posso propormi dai a
chiarano sabato c'è uno che sbadato qua
occhio o forse ma mille chili ti la
mamma mia incredibile veramente ok
abbiamo ammazzato il problema è la loro
barca e quasi tu la nostra dove lupo
vabbè allora intanto le abbiamo
affrontato la barca quindi va bene
adesso noi prendiamo la sirena abbiamo
nella nostra non è così abbiamo
affondato allora abbiamo fatto nostra la
nostra chi è che ce l'ha è un tipo
vediamo se non l'hai riuscito ad
affondarla ancora infatti no non c'è il
tizio zio non c'è no a meno che non si
sia nascosta non c'è
ho appreso dopo la sirena
aia imbarchiamo attenzione abbiamo
affondato la nave siamo contenti bene
via ci sono le teorie sul crack con il
kraken spunta solo quando hai tanti
tesori persone ci deve essere o nelle
tempeste tipo di notte forse di notte di
giorno spunta allora dice segnali e
praticamente l'acqua da azzurra diventa
molto più blu quasi nero quindi esiste
un crack
esatto il kraken oltre al fermo navara
capo trough afferrare anche dei compagni
non puoi portarmi via e mangiarli
abbiamo il nostro viaggio ancora da fare
vediamo dove dobbiamo andare nella mappa
che ci hanno dato che questa festa
sballo esattamente quello che noi siamo
adesso incredibile that's it ma guarda
ma guarda che parcheggio in mare perché
c'è uno scheletro qua pieno un papa c'è
un altro amico ho trovato una roba un po
strana secondo me qua sotto
ma poi è dimostrata secondo no no no no
no secondo me qua è esattamente dove
sono io qui ma non è vero
[Musica]
tu sei a è quello aspetta al primo
negozio è il forziere mille grog
covidien ed ubriaco qua di qui amico è
buona e stabile lì a marca che ci sono
di barili in acqua guarda dietro idea
così da far rifornimento però vai vai
all di porto recchia vacchia che male mi
ha avvelenato un serpente sono ubriaco
appena nato tutto ciò questo quadro si
venda un sacco di soldi errori per il c
eh sì perché è quello che ti rende
ubriaco
sai dove lo lascio questa volta ok l'ho
buttato giù
non so se è da geni aver fatto questa
cosa siete completamente stupidi per ora
ma è quell isola che abbiamo davanti a
sé quale dei più delle tante dalla
destra
no è questa qua con la forma di di
spazzola per capelli c'è un'oasi al
centro ci sono due ai tesori qua sì lo
so ma sei sicuro che sia il primo che
sarà come poteva questo che è semplice
ma cagate qua thatcher altro e trovando
visto che palato che sono questi si
aspettava come me
vediamo se lo sono non lo so forse del
navigatore o che hanno trovato parka
vasca più rock e paschi che si definisca
madonna chi schiaffo ma dato questo
campo una roba allucinante ha dato uno
schiaffo però sempre di genere tra
oceano
adesso se questi due così uno che entra
pensa che siano i nostri amici tesori
poi non hanno visto sulla cima
peggiorare
basta altra faremo dei geni isola forma
diretta potrebbe essere questa isola
forma di cotoletta ecco è vero che
questa de vito riggio e soft marche sud
sud est sud est da un occhio
cos'è
cosa no no no no no non ci beccano per
un niente non so perché museo pietro
questo ci becca in pieno non ci ha preso
proprio droga ma che minchia
beh
beh direi che ci siamo dimenticati di
tirare l'ancora però sono dettagli
eccolo ai denti ma adesso la forza la
viaggio completato tutta la cuesta
abbiamo fatto poi forte stato di centro
e tre casse anzi 4 dove andiamo quindi
prendere assolutamente si abbiamo 4 4
con i normali
un giorno durante come robella opposto
avamposto blundell dritto davanti a
terra vicino è vicino molto vicino
dritto dove c'è quella barca lì ma
questo potrebbe il problema resto essere
problema barca vicino essere problema da
avamposto esattamente quello che stava
dando loro andremo anche noi scopriremo
se queste due ore dice akros salita
qualcosa seguitiamo tutto nel cesso no
dai parroci ingaggiano qualsia è invece
anche rosberg invece sempre sparare non
allora ci faccio con 50 ce la faccio io
facevo a noi due abbiamo tutto tesori
non possiamo perderlo non gli ho sparato
potevamo farlo non l'abbiamo fatto che
la serie veniamo in pace su anche finire
in pace che quando si guarda e li salute
da notare come fatto secondario fare
ciao pietro e poi soccorse rubrica bene
bene mentre faiola stiamo andando
esattamente nel punto sbagliato o la
guido io
ci siamo io prendo il portiere ubriaco
il primo che consegno ok questo qua dove
la sicurezza è male ogni volta che salti
si senta una cornamusa si gonfia paco e
no al macello solo gioco
ok ho consegnato quanto 838 nice
abbiamo preso anche un patto di
reputazione quindi ragazzo li abbiamo
fatto un button i combattimenti abbiamo
preso un botto di forse era imbottito i
combattimenti è finita bene oggi nel
senso che tutte le barche che mi ha
incontrati abbiamo fatto un mazzo tanto
quindi alla fine siamo forti facciamo
andiamo da ma poi ce la caviamo dai
ragazzi che mi sia piaciuto costi
socialmente mi piace anche al
ricevimento descrizione questo gioco
rasi ortiz poi vi sia piaciuto come
socialmente descrizione sistemi
[Musica]